[Musique]
je vais être franc avec toi molly
héroïne atteindre chute de 97% c'est la
quinzième fois que tu vis ça
est-ce que vous connaissez les
antagonistes des opiacés on ne fait une
injection par ward injection immunisés
contre les effets de la drogue
c'est sans danger
tu te fous de moi d'un seul quoi tu dois
protéger ton petit corps tu peux rester
clean pendant au moins une semaine coin
encore quatre jours c'est rien
on a déjà subi beaucoup de choses j'ai
peur pour toi tu es qu'elle se trouve
dans les parages c'était qui si j'étais
pas engine qui tu me demandera même pas
probablement vie toutes les fois où j'ai
renoué avec elle je l' ai toujours fait
en pleine connaissance au fils yves
rossy je veux plus voir
maman comment elle est elle reste assise
à fumer et à trembler je suis là la
surveiller toute la journée tout en
faisant comme si je ne le faisais pas
cela fait presque une journée
[Musique]
il n'en reste plus que trois
je suis désolé j'aurais tellement voulu
être s'arrêter mif tu crois que c'est ma
faute si tu te prends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh mon dieu
[Musique]
c'est ainsi qu'une durée et dur est
vraiment du réseau les jeux ma
dépendance à la drogue sont aussi
difficiles à vivre pour toi parfois j'ai
l'impression
je préférerais ne plus l'aimer
mais
sinon plus vous savez combien de fois je
me suis dit qu'il n'était pas question
que je vole pour de la drogue je
voudrais parfois que ce soit plus facile
pour elle qu'il était pas question que
je perde la garde de mes enfants pour de
la drogue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir falloir attendre encore wendel
je suis désolé à bord
s'il ya une personne qui a la force se
libérer de cette merde c'est toi ça j'en
suis sûr je suis fier de toi
[Musique]